hey guys I'm Ryan right Alyssa be crazy
Breanna white so the ladies here today
are gonna help me unbox my super geek
box so if you will do the honors of
unveiling the first item Breanna lights
Alyssa gave me this by the way it's a
bottle opener
Batman it's more than a bottle opener
Twitter yeah and you can also murder
people with it don't show me what the
items are alright so you just put your
hand in there reach for it you're used
to reaching and dark spaces looking for
something with your hand I know you are
real alright alright don't show me item
streetfighter keychain a real baby yeah
oh man I love Street Fighter reuse my
favorite character always has been
always will be I don't care how many
[ __ ] video games you guys make Ryu
will always remain number one alright
cool
listen next time yes sir oh you ladies
are jealous
Jana butter and jelly oh that is really
cool
my sister would love this but then I
have already given her one present of
giving you a present
it's only fair congratulations Brianna
you have one really that is your present
are you jealous God you should be
jealous yeah there you go
there you go I always give away the
Zelda one even though I love Zelda and
stuff I I always give those ones away
because they mean a lot to the woman in
my life
so here you go next item another one
it's a dragon ball alright we got a
dragon ball last time we get another one
yeah stress ball it's a stress dragon
ball do you like Dragon Ball Z
where'd you go Briana every time I go to
like Denny's or
Kate place with the claw game I always
try to get the toys like this and I'm
that is so cool he's so really looking
angry Captain America yeah it's like
he's shoving his penis in something like
Black Widow but he's not enjoying it I'm
keeping this [ __ ] you guys look at Zelda
mints seldom I thank God see what Zelda
men's tastes like ladies open this for
me they look like PMS pills you ladies
are more than welcome to have it is
minty fresh breath mints ready for
what's gonna happen next you know what I
mean nothing's gonna happen I mean the
shirt the shirt oh I don't know what it
is
do you guys know that is the spirit of
war
temporary tattoo that's pretty awesome
maybe put my innocent on right now you
need to like what's the back of it
though yeah okay hold on Wow
oh there's even one more thing in here
what it's never-ending
Oh boxes surprises that's awesome does
it light up to make a sound also it's a
double whammy thick as my hair boom boom
boom
yeah I'm so fat the damn soda man
tattoos get forward to stress I just go
straight there it's so thick a little
low rep against a that it's a goop I
know it's really bad yeah no I'm sure
doesn't go on like that you yeah thank
you thank you
that is pretty thick listen exactly for
the next item my nipples are chilly Oh
hoo it's got wings this looks like Final
Fantasy could be I wish I got the tattoo
second blast just so you guys know it's
kind of weird just sitting here because
man YouTube with his shirt off right now
you know if I was like ripped it would
be like ah this guy's just cocky but
because I'm fat that I'm gonna get
people point I mean it's the sword that
strikes me as a little fan
all right last night all right this is
so not stuck to my chest this is so far
from being stuck to my chest shirt all
right people
what's up the cameras please that's what
it is
cool this totally is the kind of shirt
that would rock and none of us really
know who it's from it's final fantasy
looks like Final Fantasy anyway guys if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
also purchase a super geek box in the
description link below you can check out
Elissa be crazies channel you can check
out Brianna's Facebook channel page
Facebook page his modeling photos on
their family apparently very good photos
that's good do you cosplay well no I
would love to wear bikini photos people
check out her Facebook page I wish it
was a channel with videos page but she
has a channel coming up yep gaming a
game coming soon that's what I say
almost every time I have sex but then I
I don't I think it nervous and I feel
like she won't approve she wouldn't she
doesn't like it and when I do it it's
like she always finishes herself off but
she never lets me finish and then if I
do she gets mad at me he throws a temper
tantrum she storms out of the apartment
it's I'm sorry do you need to release
some stress that's okay I got my own
balls this way